- [Instructor] In this video, we are going
to talk about proportional relationships,
and these are relationships
between two variables where the ratio
between the variables is equivalent.
Now that sounds complex
or a little bit fancy.
It'll hopefully seem a little bit
more straightforward once
we look at some examples.
So let's say I'm looking at a recipe
for some type of baked goods,
maybe it's some type of pancakes,
I've been making a lot of those lately,
and we know that for a
certain number of eggs
how many cups of milk we need.
So we have number of eggs,
and then we're also going
to have cups of milk.
And in this recipe, we know
that if we're going to use one egg,
then we would use two cups of milk,
and if we use three eggs,
then we're gonna use six cups of milk,
and if we use, let's say, 12 eggs,
then we're going to use 24 cups of milk.
So is this a proportional relationship
where the two variables
are the cups of milk
and the number of eggs?
Well, to test that we just have
to think about the ratio
between these two variables.
And you can say that the ratio
of the number of eggs to the cups of milk,
or the ratio of the cups of milk
to the number of eggs.
But you just need to ensure that they
are always equivalent in these scenarios.
So let me make another column here,
and I'm gonna think about the ratio
of the eggs to the cups of milk.
Well, in this first scenario
one egg for two cups of milk.
This second scenario is three to six.
This third scenario is 12 to 24.
Are these equivalent ratios?
Well, to go from one to three
you multiply by three,
and also, to go from two to six,
you multiply by three.
So you multiplied both
the variables by three.
Similarly, if you multiply
the number of eggs by four,
then you multiply the number
of cups of milk by four as well.
So these indeed are all equivalent ratios,
one to two, three to six, 12 to 24.
In every scenario you have twice as much
cups of milk as you have number of eggs.
So this would be proportional.
So check.
Now what would be an example
of a non-proportional relationship?
We'll stay in this baked
goods frame of mind.
Let's say you're going to a cake store
and you're curious about how much
it would cost to buy a cake
for different numbers of people.
So let's say number of servings,
number of servings in one column,
and then the cost of the cake.
And let me set up two
columns right over here.
And so let's say if you have 10 servings,
the cake costs $20.
If you have 20 servings,
the cake costs $30.
And if you have 40 servings,
the cake costs $40.
Pause this video and see
if you can figure out
whether this is a
proportional relationship.
If it is, why?
If it isn't, why not?
Alright, well let's just think
about the ratios again.
And here our two variables are
the number of servings
and the cost of cake.
So if we look at the
ratio of the servings,
servings, to cost,
in this first situation it is 10 to 20,
and then it is 20 to 30,
and then it is 40 to 40.
And so to see if these
are equivalent ratios,
when we go from 10 to 20 on the number
of servings, we're multiplying by two.
But when we go from 20 to 30
on the cost of the cake,
we aren't multiplying by two,
we're multiplying by
1.5, or one and a half.
And similarly, when we go from 20 to 40,
we are multiplying by two again,
but to go from 30 to 40
we aren't multiplying by two,
we're multiplying by one and one third.
By one and one third.
When we multiply our
servings by a given amount,
we're not multiplying our cost of cake
by the same amount.
This tells us that this
is not proportional.
One way to think about
proportional relationships,
we already said, that the ratio
between the variables will be equivalent.
Another way to think about it is
one variable will always be some constant
times the first variable.
So in our first example right over here
we said the cups of milk is always
two times the number of eggs.
We can write that down.
So cups of milk
is always going to be equal
to two times the number of eggs.
And this number right over here,
we call that the constant
of proportionality.
And you wouldn't be able to set up
an equation like this in this scenario.
It would have to be more complicated.
And so a proportional relationship,
the ratios are equivalent
between the two variables
and you can set it up
with an equation like this
where you have a constant
of proportionality.